chose bad and fetterman's worse so who's
got dibs on the hearse
sick
over the weekend Biden went to
Pennsylvania that's a state cat to
inspect a crumbling highway but instead
met a crumbling Senator John fetterman
the crumbling Highway was actually in
better shape veteran made Biden seem
like the brains of the operation which
I'm pretty sure is an absolute first
Rolla Gwyneth and now I'm standing next
to the president again next to a
collapsed Bridge here and he is here to
commit to work with the governor and the
the delegation to make sure that we get
this fixed quick fast as well too this
is a president that is committed to
infrastructure yeah and then on top of
that the the jewel
kind of a
law of the in French inflation uh bill
I know first you're laughing and then
you feel dirty when you're laughing he's
like Yoda he's bald and can't speak
usually they see someone mutilate the
English language like that you have to
watch Jesse Watters prime time
and he didn't have a stroke
Biden's no better watch
you'd see a truck pull up pull to the
curb and selling weapons
selling guns selling AR-15 selling
weapons
well guess what you do that now you go
to jail it made it harder for people to
buy stabilized braces put a pistol on a
brace it turns into a gun
make some more you can have a higher
caliber weapon a higher caliber bullet
coming out of that gun
I believe that's impossible first no one
has ever seen a truck pull up and just
starts selling weapons
of course outside of Ukraine
second all a pistol praise does is
attach to the gun to attach the gun to
your arm so it could be more easily
fired using one hand don't you miss the
days when Joe talked about Corn Pop
I mean that actually made sense by
comparison where's Katie Pavlich when
you need her probably out shooting
elephants for lunch
and all right God Save the Queen man
all right God Save the Queen man
[Applause]
[Laughter]
or like God help us so this is more sad
than funny but it's how a one-party
system works when it controls the media
it's a true Emperor has no close
scenario but it's a president and two
senators it reminds me of a former
Soviet leader Leonid breznav his health
famously deteriorated after several
Strokes leaving him practically a
cabbage his eyebrows though kept living
it up
the party in the media hid it from the
public you think our media would see
some parallels here they did once a
historian wrote about bereshnep in 2020
but of course compared him to Trump you
know we reached out to see if she'll
compare Biden to president if no
surprise she declined weird guess
competency is only what you expect from
a republican what's Joe gotta say
come on man I like
I like him he makes me look good I might
take him on the campaign trail with me
that's going to be my slogan a better
man than Fetter man
I mean I might forget my wife's name
every once in a while but this guy he
starts a speech with good night
everybody
I gotta be careful though I mean he uh
he sets the bar so low I might drip and
fall
you know
Bill I've been trying to figure out who
uh Joe was referring to when he said God
saved the queen and I think it might
have been Rachel Levine
possible she might be on the list I you
know I think with fetterman I think it's
unfortunate you look more a last couple
of days especially
um he's not well and that's a shame for
him and his family yeah as for the
president I I saw him in Connecticut on
Friday so I'm in Philadelphia on
Saturdays in California today and
there's not a single sandbag around not
one in sight but when a senator shows up
and he's dressed for gym class I mean
what do you do yeah yeah you know you
try and talk him out of it I mean I get
it you need clothes that are easy to put
on and take off or you'll be there for
days
speaking for myself
guy everybody gets really touchy about
this yeah oh my God if you'd laugh or
say it's able you're being ableist is
that the word ableist are you being are
you being ageist well we're not running
for office we're not the president I
think nothing everything is on the table
and you're seeing it axios wrote a story
about some of the things that come out
of the president's mouth like God saved
the queen man and I'm just going to
quote axio said that Republicans are
weaponizing Biden's quote quirky
aphorisms
that's the way they decided to describe
that and look if we didn't have any form
of recording device in society yes and
we were just taking their word for it
then maybe we would say oh we have a
president who's a bit older and he has
quirky aphorisms that the other party's
weaponizing the problem for axios and
for Biden is that we have cameras yeah
and recording devices and we have seen
him say things that are not quirky
aphorisms they're nonsensical blather
yeah and we know his age and that is
something that I think is fair to
consider and talk about and occasionally
even joke about on a show like this yeah
you know you just made me think and
that's hard
try not to think cat what that guy said
that guy said
imagine before when we didn't have
modern technology we had no idea what if
a lot of our presidents were like that
we just didn't know
it's possible yes uh I my favorite
defense though guy in the axios piece
and some other pieces was it's
ridiculous for conservatives to be
pouncing on this because it's not the
first time he said God Save the Queen
when it makes no sense
okay
okay how is that better
like you know he never makes sense so
he's consistent about that but nobody
really cares I don't think people care
it's it's I don't know if it's more sad
to watch that or to watch that knowing
that I still could never get elected
yeah no it's amazing and you wouldn't
let this guy fly your plane or operate
on your kid but have him run the largest
freest country in the world Rob even
like it's amazing like if you look at
late night comedy nobody's it's like
this is should be a nightly conversation
this should be on every single night
what did he I mean remember Chevy Chase
going after Gerald Ford because he
tripped once remember well the fetterman
thing is like look
just because you can't talk doesn't mean
you can't dress nicely yeah you know but
it's it's you know he goes to Neiman
Marcus and it's hard for the guys to get
like shirt fire bad me hey I need a
shirt for the back of my head you know
it's hard I said they want to get him
out of the store just give him a
quadruple hoodie and some some
basketball shorts and get them out of
here you know he's affecting our
business right now yeah
I used to love dressing like that but
now I can't because it's the fetterman
look
s me fire bad fire bad
yeah but you better not point this stuff
out if you point this stuff out you know
you're cruel you're cruel and you're
right I am cruel but I'm also honest all
right up next the academy holds down the
scales to keep out the straight white
male hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else